I feel like I just made out with the
gingerbread man it's delicious
um I personally love Harry Potter I
remember seeing the cover and I was like
I have to read this my relationship to
Harry Potter I've never met the man I'm
so excited
this drink is beautiful this is a tall
glass of sexy right here my gosh whoo
that's sweet
yeah my goodness that's so sweet stuff
oh that's good it's caramel a it's
butterscotch a just happiness in a cup
it could use a little more salt I think
part of me wants to say it can't be
related to anything else is exclusive to
Harry Potter and butter beer but the
other half of me wants to say uh cream
soda I could knock back a few of these
with Dobby oh yeah I could drink this
every day I could have this breakfast
start off my day this way so this is the
frozen one oh this one looks like a
milkshake well well Cheers
if Hogsmeade had a 7-eleven baby this
would be their Slurpee or slushy oh my
gosh it's not as sweet it tastes kind of
a little bit watery dare I say it's sad
that I want to say this tastes like a
caramel Frappuccino ooh
better put better the other one is also
really good and it has like a lot more
of the creamy top he I keep on saying
creamy top and I'm like so here's the
thing so Harry Potter always were almost
always went back to the muggle world in
the summers and that's when he'd want to
drink this I wouldn't want to know how
much sugar is in this Oh does it count
and Harry Potter world got the ice cream
headache oh yeah what are the smells I
got rid of that you can't do spells at
the table Oh
it's nice and warm Cheers you know I
imagined butterbeer TBH I hope this is a
transformative experiences like pumpkin
spice latte was it smells like a candle
I feel like this is gonna be a very
hipster butterbeer what Oh
holy whoa I want to I want to enjoy us
in private it's just one of those it's
so good I feel like they melted down a
waffle
it tastes like buttered corn on the cob
kind of yeah I disagree it's way better
than corn on the cob this is like
Christmas in a cup this is my perfect
everything
I don't know I honestly like I know I'm
taking the easy road out right here but
I cannot pick one the hot one the frozen
one like a ball every day the hot one is
definitely my favorite this defied all
my expectations this one's my favorite
one because it's the more subtle of the
tastes butter beer at the budget of
World of Harry Potter is everything that
I dreamed it would be
specifically the hot butter beer holy
crap this was my favorite one
I just wanted it's more bathe in this I
would do Alohomora and have it just
floating behind me oh and then hold the
other tail
but there was idea it was actually
alcoholic in the books like they were
getting tipsy